[موسيقى]
نشات في بيئه شعر وادب ورسم وفهم وكلمه
والدي هو اللي اكتشف الموهبه منذ الصغر
وكان يشجعني على الرسم باستمرار
[موسيقى]
الانطلاقه كانت من ذكرياتي الشخصيه
التراثي الشخصي في احدى نواحي بغداد اسمها
كراده مريم
كانت الطبيعه المصدر الثاني لالهامي
وبعدها المصدر الثالث هو طبعا المراه
باستمراريه هذه العناصر وتفاعلها اعطى دفع
مستمر
للانتاج الفني عندي
بدات التقنيات اولا تستهوني تقنيات
الطباعه والجرافيك الى ان تمزج بين
الاحساس بالطباعه والجرافيك والاحساس
بالفريدي انجزت كثير من الاعمال
وكذلك انجزت جداريات
بهم خامات كثيره مثل البرونز وغيرها وهذاك
طبعا كله ينصاب في مجال الفن الحديث
عندما قصفت بغداد من الطائرات في
التسعينات كان دافع لان ابدا مجموعه جديده
عن البيوت وعن الذاكره الطفوله وجمال
الحاره والبيت والعماره بتبسيط شديد في في
بغداد ومن بعدها انطلقت هذه التجربه
وتطورت الى ان تصير 3d وتصير
استخدمت الحرف العربي للتشكيل وللتاويل
مهم جدا ان الانسان يبحث عن المشتركات
الانسانيه
ومن اهم المشتركات الانسانيه هي الثقافه
والتشكيل والشعر والادب والفنون بشكل عام
والموسيقى وغيرها وانا من هنا ادعو الى
الاستمتاع بالفن والاستمتاع بحلم الفن
وبجمالياته
[موسيقى]